une captation améliorer c'est dans ce
projet que l'équipe artistique du
spectacle variété s'est lancée trois
jours de tournage au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines pour allier
cinéma et théâtre le but casser le
quatrième mur pour réaliser un film de
théâtre on va un peu plus loin que la
captation avec l'idée qu'on va aller en
dehors du théâtre on va suivre l'actrice
principale qui va être sortir de chez
elle prendre les transports en commun
rentrer dans le théâtre et que des
fronts bas si choper des bouts de des
instants où l'acteur est dans la loge se
prépare pour est dans le théâtre et
créer un peu une à orchamps répétition
tournage et représentations tout a été
réalisé en une semaine
objectif pour les artistes se replonger
dans un processus de création et
apporter un plus au projet je trouvais
important que ce soit aussi une création
que ce soit pas seulement filmer la
pièce telle qu'elle est mais que nous on
se remette au travail et qu'on puisse
inventer des choses nouvelles et qu'on
soit dans un mouvement de création
ils vont utiliser la totalité du lieu
ils sont venus en repérage ici pour
réécrire une partie du spectacle et la
façon l'endroit où se déroule certaines
actions certaines scènes et c'est donc
ce sens un spectacle filmé entendent
qu'ovide élan passe juste un spectacle
filmé sur scène dans une ambiance
intimiste pianiste chanteuse et
journalistes se retrouvent pour parler
musique c'est l'émission de télévision
des années 60 discorama qui inspirait le
spectacle variétés
vous pouvez me rappeler le nom de la
chanson qui vous a fait gagner leur
audition oui il n'y a pas de route
y'a pas de oui y'a pas de nom nous on a
écrit un spectacle qui dure le temps de
l'émission qui a été diffusée de 1958 à
donc c'est 15 ans d'émission est on est
on tout est centré sur la relation à une
chanteuse donc c'est en fait plusieurs
interviews d'une même chanteuse qui
s'appelle veronica mai et ses 15 ans
comme ça de vie qui passe donc il ya à
la fois la vie de la chanteuse mais
aussi l'avis de la france tous les
événements qui traverse un peu cette
histoire en une heure
le film sera diffusé sur le site du
théâtre le 8 avril prochain
[Musique]